the first call was to my family that was
a very first call Matthew Knowles
opening up about his breast cancer
diagnosis on Good Morning America
Wednesday morning and how his family
including daughter Beyonce handled the
news because this is genetics it also
means that my kids have a higher chance
a higher risk even my grandkids have a
higher risk and they handle it like they
should they went and got the test the 67
year old is part of the 1% of men
diagnosed with breast cancer I have that
Brocker
too that's mutated which means I have 4
things to be concerned about prostate
cancer pancreatic cancer melanoma and
breast cancer the rest of my life I have
to be very much aware and conscious and
do all of the early detection but
Matthew seems to be taking everything in
stride I'm doing really good Michael I
had my surgery the last week of 2i and
now doing all the steps for recovery
things that used to be important Michael
they're not important to me now just
look at the world differently we're
hoping this also means that all is well
with Matthew and Queen B the singer left
her father's management years ago and
shortly after reports surfaced that the
two were feuding I won't get into great
detail of that but I only say that it
was time for me to be a dad and not a
manager
this past Grammys I watched beyoncé's
performance for the very first time from
the eyes of a dad and not from the eyes
of a manager and I cried because I had
always looked at a performance from the
eyes of a manager that was Noel's
addressing the rumors back in 2015 and
both father and daughter have since
instagrammed these adorable family
photos
[Music]